you say say russe et bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode de ask donc le quatrième
épisode comme le second ça sera un live
il ya pas mal de choses qui ont changé
par rapport au premier live déjà la
durée
il va être beaucoup plus court on va
essayer de viser les 20 minutes
et pour ça du coup on l'a pas mal
préparée en amont avec les participants
qui sont mais si vous vous présenter
alors moi c'est michou à mi chemin
j'essaie de suivre ton conseil regardez
vers la caméra du coup je suis en master
1 en droit des affaires et je vais être
gentil et je vais essayer de d'apporter
des précisions comment ça marche dans le
droit français sur la question du droit
des animaux et c'est pour ça que aussi
aux matchs choisi parce que j'ai côté
juridique
on pourrait ajouter au côté
philosophique alors maintenant passons
alexis c'est moi alexis gaudrée je suis
pas juriste je suis juste féministe est
intéressé par la philosophie à mes
heures perdues donc je suis là en tant
que personne qui relaient donc ouais en
fait on est on est partis du postulat
que le droit des animaux on a fait ce
qu'on a commencé à mettre en place avec
les exemples dont je vous parlais sur la
page facebook c'est à dire la souris la
souris la plus grande exactement et un
pareil avec cette orangs outans qui a un
statut maintenant de personnes non
humaine et qui a été retiré du zoo et
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on a
commencé à faire
je pense que c'est une bonne chose
puisque en fait ne pas accorder de
droits aux animaux c'est de faire du
sexisme du spécisme partie du spécisme
c'est à dire c'est discriminatoire comme
au même titre que le racisme et le
sexisme c'est à dire qu'en fait tu
prends l'espèce humaine et tu dis
qu'elle est supérieur aux autres
on s'est posé la question de jusqu'où il
faut aller dans le droit dans le droit
des animaux
et là il ya michou qui qui déjà m'avait
dit un truc sur le droit des animaux
ouais donné ce que j'avais fait expliqué
c'était comment ça marche
le droit des animaux en france parce que
faut savoir que on a une distinction
fondamentale entre les personnes à côté
et les choses de l'autre les animaux
sont dans les choses du coup c'est quoi
la différence entre les deux c'est que
les personnes et vont être titulaires de
droits et obligations
c'est à dire qu'elles vont pas on peut
vendre quelque chose
du coup qu'est ce qu'elles vont prendre
chose donc un animal sauf que animaux
sont des choses un peu particulière
parce que l on le côté chose mais aussi
le côté êtres vivants et ses gardes
on aura des des conséquences en tant que
chose tu le propriétaire et bien il sera
responsable des accidents qui aura
l'animé avant si ton chien il va
agresser quelqu'un sait ce que tu me
disais cyrus du coup si la grèce
quelqu'un parfois on tue l'animal
comment ça se fait pas parce qu'en vrai
que c'est une chose dangereuse on soit
on va là confisqué mes vitrines mais
l'on peut pas confisquer donc on va le
détruire donc le pic est quoi en tant
qu'être vivant on lui accorde quand même
des protections donc son propriétaire il
peut pas peut pas lui occasionner des
souffrances il peut pas porter atteinte
à l intégrité comme une personne du coup
et tout ça on ne retrouve dans le code
rural si jamais quelqu'un veut faire des
recherches mais bon du coup on s'est
posé la question du talent au niveau de
l'article et où l'article 74
elle 214-1 du code rural voilà
si quelqu'un est passionné de toad rural
l214 aller chercher l'arctique qui dit
en gros que les animaux sont doux et
sensibilité d'ailleurs si ça vous
intéresse aussi il ya une non par un peu
en ce moment c'est qu'ils ont voulu
mettre ça mais dans le code civil
sachant que le code civil c'est le code
de base celui que qu'on apprend au début
sauf que moi il voulait mettre sa
l'assemblée nationale avait dit oui mais
senna ensuite à 10 n'ont donc on sait
pas trop ce qui va arriver on s'était
pas aujourd'hui ça il ya trois jours
la louve d'or bien lu le scénario et
voilà peuvent du coup on sait pas trop
ce qui va se passer parce que le
l'assemblée nationale va relire le texte
bon on verra bref du coup on se posait
la question est ce que on parle vraiment
de droits de l'animal ou plutôt des
devoirs qu'on imposerait à l'homme pour
protéger un animal ou éviter des
souffrances et voilà du coup bah je vous
lance sur ce débat comment ces problèmes
il prouve le dingue cour formulé on
reformule en fait la question non mais
du coup la question avons formulé sais
pas jusqu'où doit aller le droit des
animaux c'est jusqu'où doit aller le
devoir de lob de l'homme ouais de
l'homme sur les animaux et en fait je
vous parlais du spécisme tout à l'heure
si on veut aller à l'encontre du
spécisme et bien si on pose cette
question par exemple est ce qu un orang
outan méritent les mêmes droits qu'un
poisson rouge parce que animaux pour
poser les bases c'est quelque chose de
très bas instincts animaux c'est tout ce
qui est multi c'est exactement le genre
un acarien ça peut être considéré comme
comme un animal un insecte etc voilà
donc du coup en fait tu poses la
question est ce qu un orang outan
méritent les mêmes droits qu'un poisson
rouge attend il ya 1 commentaire je le
fais intervenir maintenant à temps
mais à partir du moment où l'animal fait
du mal à un être humain le propriétaire
l'animal ne t'y pas s'opposer à la
décision de piquer l'animal autant le
dresser plutôt que le faire disparaître
mais le mal est déjà fait en fait à
verser au moment où il a mordu ou
blesser un être humain c'est pas
rétroactif donc la décision elle est
plein il me semble que la décision est
prise par rapport à ce qui est fait de
base va déjà le fait qu'il ait mordu
c'est qu'il n'avait pas dressé aussi
donc le propriétaire avait déjà fait une
faute donc que et en plus c'est
considéré comme une chose dangereuse
dans ce cas là oui pourra toujours
s'opposer
ça va pas décider comme ça il va aller
devant les tribunaux et tous les mails
va pas se faire piquer direct et si le
juge décide au final qui doit se faire
piquer bas ils sont rapides et quoi
faudrait juste qu'il se défende il peut
donc voilà du coup attend gens pensent
qu'ils utilisèrent ouais je parlais de
l'orang outan des poissons et en vo mois
à priori j'ai envie de répondre non à
cette question a priori mais si je suis
ce qu'on a dit sur le spécisme tout à
l'heure et que en fait toutes les
espèces sont égales enfin égal devant la
loi ou devant le droit il faudrait
répondre oui un orang outan mais avec
les mêmes droits qu'un crois qu'un
poisson rouge etc
et là ça pose en termes de vie pratique
genre par exemple si on doit en aidant
on nous on est dans une société
construite par l'homme et pour l'homme
donc tu vois pas comment on peut donner
la même place un poisson rouge dans la
société
quand même parce qu'un homme parce que
tu ne dis un truc très juste alexis ce
que donnait du le droit le droit donne
la place à quelqu'un dans la société et
finalement ça ça de loi c'est là parce
que tu n'as ce nom
puis les trois en même temps que les
devoirs du coup et c'est maya il ya
vraiment un paradoxe là dedans et c'est
la question du spécisme et de l'andi
spécisme du coup pose vraiment problème
par rapport à cette question là bas donc
ce qu'il fera en pratique pas ce
pessimisme à fond mais peut-être une
classification mais du coup on reprend
vaste histoire de classification la vue
c'est comme
nous a dit qu'on avait discuté un petit
peu avant ça on a vu que la
classification fallait vraiment pas
qu'elle dépende de la culture parce que
si on en établit que d'un petit peu
maintenant de voir que en france et en
europe majoritairement on peut pas faire
des choses du type manger du chien parce
que vous faire vraiment du mal à un
animal de compagnie alors qu en inde et
en asie on peut verser genre de
pratiques mais manger une vache c'est
totalement impensable du coup la
classification l'escouade est vraiment
vraiment trop subjective et en os et en
essayant de réfléchir à d'autres
solutions et de m
aucun aucun spécisme questions sur la
classification quand une
déclassification
c'est une classification à quel point
parce que georges rémi dit je pense que
le problème ce qu'il y a des centaines
d'espèces d'animaux donc faire une loi
pour chaque espèce prendrait beaucoup de
temps je pense pas que l'homme va
prendre le temps d'imposer une loi pour
chaque espèce
bah du coup non mais ce serait je pense
peut-être pas pour chaque espèce mais
faire des groupes d'animaux du coup qui
se ressemblent mais déterminé la
classification en fait là c'est juste
déterminer quel genre de solution vous
pourrez prendre pour régler ce problème
et la classification en fait partie
comment classifier c'est une autre
question en fait
et du coup la question qui se pose est
c'est que madiba
est-ce qu'on peut essayer de faire
quelque chose en dehors totalement de la
classification parce que juste pas comme
une personne vient de souffler problème
c'est que laquelle l'assuré question
risque d'être trop subjectif donc on va
prendre l'eau perte immédiate va en fait
aucun spécisme aucune aucune
classification du tout toutes les
espèces se valent et c'est quelque chose
que j'avais dit avant avec sur lequel on
était tombés d'accord c'est que balancer
comme ça c'est très facile pour les
végétaliens et les gens qui sont légales
parce que dans leur vie est quasiment
rien qui qui fait qu'ils ont eu besoin
dans l'animal il les laisse tranquilles
et c'est très bien mais pour le reste de
la planète qui ont des besoins
fondamentaux en matière de ti peut
manger et se vêtir
on fait comment on fait parce que
j'avais pris l'exemple de quand on veut
construire une maison si c'est le film
voilà ça si on ne consomme une maison
comme on fait parce que j'avais pris
l'exemple de sept ans au tibet avec brad
pitt ou pour resituer voilà ce que sept
ans au tibet c'est un défi ils veulent
construire un temple et comme la
religion la religion là bas fait que
tous les animaux on doit protéger tous
les animaux et bien ils sont un peu dans
la merde puisque avant de placer ses
places et chaque pierre il va vous
retirer tous les vers de terre de la
terre puisque l'esprit de ton grand père
pouvait être dedans et tu peux quand
même pas tous espèrent donc ça tant
mieux et encore là l'exemple est
vachement important parce que l'esprit
du grand père c'est quoi c'est un truc
liées à l'homme tu vois donc dans cet
exemple
mais moi j'ai une question est-ce qu'il
faudra même bouger les criquets aller
mais obligé de respecter la forêt et
tout ça en plus rien fait on serait
obligé d'arrêter l'évolution est ce que
ceci est une solution des gens qui
dirait ça brûle faisons en suisse active
de notre voilà c'est ça le truc et en
plus même quand tu redescends en fait
imaginons dit bon bah on fait en
minimise notre impact à fond ouais bah
finalement tu as on redescend une sorte
je vais appeler ça un état de nature
mais même si c'est loin d'être un état
naturel sont à nos voix et c'est un
machin on soit imaginer que c'est pas
possible français s'est pas réellement
fait quoi voilà bah en vrai notre état
qui serait encore pire tu vois ce genre
parce que le couteau ou les vêtements et
ses peintures montrent à l'homme de
néandertal
c'était bien les animaux oui et puis de
toute façon il me semble que enfin là
les considérer comme des égaux au final
c'est je ne suis pas dans le fait qu'on
n'a pas les considérer comme des égaux
du tout mais si on choisit sa il ya un
gros problème c'est que par rapport à
elle
augmentation et le respect et
l'environnement et tout ça en fait les
animaux entre eux il s'occupe pas de ça
le lion est ce qui pas de savoir si ça
bouge la faune et la flore deçà de sa
savane que d'aller tuer une diesel dans
la journée quoi cette manière l'homme on
a besoin de l'animal parce que tu as tu
disais l'exemple du lion qui va chasser
à gaz et à lille se pose pas de
questions pourquoi nous on devrait se
poser de questions quand on va chasser
la vache en font la chasse pas mais
quand on va tuer lavage pour manger ou
quand on va récupérer du coton et donc
ça c'est le propre de l'homme tu vois
c'est parce que il peut il se pose pas
toutes ces questions nous le fait est
que on se les pose et on a raison de se
les poser et et on en a consommé à qu'on
considère que c'est quelque chose de
mauvais cette discrimination qui est
faite entre les espèces et on assure que
là tu vois par contre le problème c'est
que si comme tu le dis tu vois cette
classification
le problème c'est que elle nous fait
retomber dans un spécisme où l'homme est
un petit peu au dessus en fait c'est ça
c'est qu'en voyant les deux les deux
propositions qu'on a amené jusque là
parce que un peu réfléchi et les deux
solutions qui fonctionne pour l'instant
c'est le spécisme donc la classification
et l'absence de ce fait si l'absence de
classification mais dans les deux il ya
un problème le problème de la conscience
et le problème de l'état naturel
donc là il faudrait faire un compromis
entre les deux pour trouver une solution
et ça bah ouais en fait le truc serbe
s'est on s'est vite rendu compte que
l'on pouvait tourner en rond pendant des
heures en dix ans bah il faut donner un
droit machin a tout fait mais en donnant
un droit
on se positionne encore une fois en tant
que les spéciaux docteur ses protecteurs
dans ce cas là on rejette ça et on
minimise notre impact sur sur les
animaux enfin
l'homme sait plus où se place là dedans
et en fait pour avancer on a été obligé
d'admettre et c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire là d'adn est que si on
veut cette classification
il faut accepter que supériorité de
l'homme mais une façon me touche parce
que tu en penses toi sur le fait que le
droit c'est quand même une création de
l'homme tu vois ça tu vois pas d'autre
solution
c'est même totalement une création met à
plusieurs philosophes qui sont partis
là-dessus avec rousseau et son contrat
social semble que locke aussi avait fait
une question de contrat aux week a
complètement et du coup en créant le
droit si sordo qualification revient de
toujours où il faut en créer des groupes
et pour rentrer dans ces groupes on met
en place des critères et quand tu
rentres quand tu coches toutes les
casses tu peux entrer dans le groupe
ayant ses reins à quelqu'un qui dans les
commentaires qui l'a très bien dit aux
mains jablonski qui part exactement des
fêtes qu'on peut faire des groupes
d'animaux par des caractéristiques
oui mais voilà c'est ce qu'on disait
plutôt c'est que dans black là dans la
classification
c'est un mode de pensée et que après
dans la classification
chacun se débrouille pour pour tout
choisir en fait c'est juste c'est juste
une façon la classification juste une
façon de penser mais à l'intérieur
chacun le d6 comme dieu et c'est ce que
c'était sorti au début par rapport au
choix culturels et aux choix personnels
et le problème en fait une question
pourquoi on refuse le spécisme c'est que
même si on dit que c'est pas une chose
horrible c'est la classification serait
beaucoup trop personnel et si on va
faire un droit pour ça dans quelque
chose qui reconnaîtra où tout le monde
que tout le monde doit suivre tout le
monde à se reconnaître
il faut pas que ce soit trop subjectif
sinon c'est encore une fois du cas par
cas et en droit et pour gérer un peuple
et au gouvernement parce que c'est
relativement compliqué de faire du cas
par cas
ouais d'ailleurs tu me disais un truc
intéressant mais je fous là dessus sur
ces parkas et le droit romain et oui
c'est que en droit romain un droit qui a
duré quand même un millénaire 1500 ans à
peu près même dominant et baï faisait
que du cas par cas et quand ils ont ils
avaient un espèce de code avec eux je
sais pas combien de me le dit gestes et
les rangs des ctt je sais plus trop je
mélange un peu mes vrais fils avait il
est vraiment tout au cas par cas y est
le problème qui se posait c'est que
quand il avait un nouveau problème et
balises étaient obligés de poser de
nouvelles bases pour ce problème là
alors que en ce moment ce qu'on fait
nous c'est qu'on pose une règle générale
et à partir de cette règle générale est
bon on va pouvoir résoudre tous les
problèmes et c'est pour ça que le fait
de de créer des groupes et des
classifications ça permet de prendre en
compte tous les tous les animaux va
permettre certains critères et banon
certains animaux qui vont remplir ces
critères la météo qui pensent pas
forcément enfin du coup quand ça dansait
devant
est ce que c'est que je fais comment les
classifications dans le droit ou pas
tout le temps présente pour les contrats
des tas les contrats de vente et contrat
de mandat les contrats de machin bas ça
c'est une classification où on a
tellement tout le temps tous les
courants droit sont des classifications
à chaque fois ans fait on fait d'abord
une première classification une deuxième
un site 8,3 en fait un rapport à la
question que on est en train de se poser
moi je parlais du de l'idée d'avoir
aucun spécisme bas on se rend compte que
c'est pas possible du tout au niveau
administratif et même au niveau humain
on est content à faire ça tout le temps
donc en fait il faudrait pour répondre à
la question il faudrait mettre en place
une classification qui soit subjectif
donc par rapport à nous trois ce qu'on y
réfléchisse et savoir si les autres sont
d'accord ou pas là la meilleure
classification possible qu'on puisse
faire pour l'instant
quand commence plutôt classe faire avec
quelqu'un par exemple
c'est pourquoi on refuse de spécimens on
l'a dit un peu juste avant c'est que
l'homme est le seul animal afin
différence entre le bien et le mal enfin
comme nous on peut se permettre on se
pose la question qu'on ne pourrait pas
simplement abusé des animaux comme le
font les lions du coup ça nous place
déjà en dehors des animaux qui aux 100
foot mais avec gérard choisi la voie la
tête ça va c'est pour ça qu'il faut
admettre le spécisme on veut pas le
rejeter
oui mais c'est juste que si on admet le
spécisme homme admet aussi que on
pourrait ne pas l'admettre
donc la question se pose en fait même si
là on est en train de se dire que c'est
pas une solution
je vais y réfléchir c'est juste le fait
d'avancer compte 28 sélections plus le
spécisme au final c'est un mal
nécessaire entre guillemets mais oui
voilà pour l'instant ça va mal mais
c'est parce que c'était n'est pas prête
à devenir végétalienne et demain et du
coup en fait ce qu'ils disaient c'est
que bon bah en fait on sait pourquoi on
parle dedans de nous enfin d'absence de
spécisme puisque son se rend compte que
s'il y en a qu'on est obligé de le faire
parce que justement comme on est des
êtres conscients on va dire qu'on a
réfléchi au problème
ce mot sur le concept est qu on appelle
ça du spécisme c'est bien qu'il ya
quelque chose en dehors de ça c'est pas
le terme n'existe pas de lui même donc
l'important c'était le fait d'y
réfléchir
et là en y réfléchissant ans avant qu'on
s'est rendu compte que ce n'était pas
possible
et maintenant qu'on sait que c'est pas
possible on va essayer de mettre en
place les meilleurs choix possibles
enfin il faudrait mettre en place les
meilleurs choix possibles pour que ceux
ci fonctionnent fonctionne sans que ce
soit trop clivant et gratuit novateur ou
quand une des meilleur choix possible
tumeur la classification
c'est dans le spécisme là on rentre on
concrètement ça ferait quoi
dans le questionnaire leur droit voire
différents critères
mais quel point la paix laquelle le taux
de conscience de soi de la conscience
que la demande donc typiquement l'orang
outan en fait la femelle orang-outan
c'est typiquement comme ça que ça s'est
passé pour elle parce que c'est après
avoir fait comprendre très clairement
assez à ses dresseurs way s'est adressé
aux gens qui s'occupait d'elle qu'elle
voulait sa liberté bien d'ailleurs
certainement obligé lui donner quoi
oui non je n'ai que de la sueur ça
faisait vachement pokémon mais je pense
pas non plus
j'ai en fait j'ai hésité entre conserver
guérisseur mais dans les deux cas
c'était beaucoup trop geek comme terme
du coup chose est sûre ça fait un peu
moi non le passé pascal champvert
voilà donc mais on peut s'arrêter de
fonctionner le temps que j'aille
chercher le véritable amour n a pas de
souci cependant ce à quoi je pense que
je pense que c'est véritablement
dresseur n'a même pas guéri soigneur non
c'est pas ça non plus mais ce truc c'est
quelqu'un dont les demandes et retrouve
le mousseux serait ce serait parfait
pour les enfants tu t'es bien dresseur
de dauphins dresseur très bien samba
hockey du coup nous voilà donc s'ils ont
conscience de soi un autre qu'un pour me
dire que je disais que du coup le niveau
de conscience de soi ça voudrait dire
que plus l'animal très conscience de soi
puis dorée des droits qui le protège
dans ce sens là voilà c'est tout tu peux
tu viens graduelle exactement d'accord
moi je pense qu'il faudrait aussi
incorporer la conscience des autres
c'est à dire avoir conscience de soi
c'est bien mais avoir conscience de son
environnement avoir conscience des
autres etc
c'est aussi un autre groupe a par
exemple avec la place dans la cité au
final oui clairement clairement ça c'est
clairement ce genre c'est une chose
pour laurent autant par exemple dans le
lot des rats [ __ ] je peux pas bouger
je suis pas libre entre guillemets c'en
est une autre de se dire [ __ ] ça l'a
pas être libre en fête
alors je suis en captivité par espèce et
ça fait c'est laurence la planète de
change
ouais ça c'est clairement clémencin
ailleurs j'avais justement après ce
commentaire je le vois que je vais le
lire je vais pouvoir par la nécessité
d'une classification finalement le
respect de leur vie et de leur
indépendance et tout ce que nous faisons
aux animaux oui mais en fait c'est juste
pour refaire ce qu'on a fait avant c'est
que je sais pas si on l'a dit mais il me
semble que je peux et on leur fait déjà
du mal donc
c'est ça sert à rien de ce d'avoir des
se voiler la face en disant bon ben on
les laisse tranquilles et puis c'est
tout parce qu'il ya beaucoup trop de
choses qui sont déjà en place ou les
laissent pas tranquille on leur laisse
pas leur indépendance et du coup bas et
je pense qu'il serait très compliqué de
avancer cet argument un peu trop simple
aux gens qui ont besoin des animaux dans
leur vie tous les jours on avait parlé
et la science si aujourd'hui vous ne
mourrez pas à 30 ans et grâce au test
qu'on a fait sur les animaux quoi donc
sa tension pacification
soit on a aimé une protection pour tous
les animaux dans ce cas là bas tu manges
plus animal tu fais plus d'expérience tu
peux plus tondre la laine enfin tu fais
plus rien moi au contraire tu acceptes
tout du coup tu peux manger du chien tu
peux manger du chat du coup le fait de
faire une classification ça permet de
protéger des animaux pas pareil que les
autres
voilà et surtout c'est exactement la
façon dont un comme si russa a commencé
cette discussion en disant à un poisson
rouge ne pas avoir le même les lannoy
corps autant mais peut-être que le
poisson rouge ça reste un peu trop gros
encore et la carie on ne peut pas avoir
le même droit
cain d'un chat ou qu'une vache parce que
c'est un être vivant c'est un email mais
c'est aussi un parasite du coup et c'est
pour ça qu'on a besoin de déterminer
l'importance de ces animaux dans
l'environnement parce que les animaux
c'est un terme très très très large
possible d'imaginer au si on devait
genre respecter l'avis des acariens tard
mon pote on écoute tu te laves plus en
fait bon changé depuis mon gars pourtant
comme nous mais pour respecter la vie de
ton ver solitaire
tu peux pas je peux pas faire ça c'est
son ami quentin réside en même temps
vous êtes cpq est une nuit at-on enfin
on va tomber un peu sur les s'appelle
vous abordé que les lois d'asimov tu vas
tu peux pas être si on va revenir au nom
revenons au louvre elle a décrété un
malaise dès 12 heures mais on pourra une
fois en selle donc ouais sur la
classification de conscience de soi
conscience des autres michaud qui les
intéressait logement l'intérêt de
l'animal ce parce qu'un intérêts
distincts de l'homme parce qu'on a nous
intérêt à nous et les intérêts d'année
le mot pardon j'ai un peu de mal
l'intérêt de l'animal ça pourrait être
une un critère étudié puisque quand on
fait du droit
on va essayer de protéger des intérêts
donc par exemple pour un chien il aurait
un intérêt à ce que son maître n'abuse
pas de lui il sourit qui laboratoire on
pourrait protéger l'intérêt du fait de
ne pas abuser de des expériences sur l
mon simple bizarre mais ça justement le
fait de dire qu'il ya pas beaucoup
d'intérêt à protéger sa pourrais ça
pourrait faire ça pour elle a classé
encore en dessous et ainsi de suite une
vache par exemple on pourrait pas lui
mettre de protection à moins en moins
d'éviter de la faute dans une batterie
par l oms la fronde sous histoire de
pouvoir la manger en parlant de ces ça
peut faire plus que nous faisons et
surtout j'essaie de faire des blagues
golf bon c'est bien ses biens personnels
contenus et donc forcément déjà entendu
non je disais forcément en fait je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui vont arriver en
cours de route et qui se pose la
question de pourquoi la classique ce
qu'on est en train de faire c'est papa
parle a rappelé à chaque fois oui non
mais je pense qu'elle me semble que
c'est pas éclairé c'est juste que là ce
qu'on fait c'est très subjectif s'est vu
qu'on n'a pas discuté avant c'est un
avis de la mini société de cyrus niche
michou et de moi donc forcément
forcément dans notre petit microcosme de
trois personnes reliées par les internet
c'est un fonctionne et mais peut-être
que en dehors de ça ça ne fonctionne pas
donc c'est pour ça que les ordres de
classification soumis dans ce sens là
c'est personnel déplacement en faveur de
pau de questions qui se posent sur le
chat en tu disais pardon je pense à la
guerre bosch est pris on a tellement par
exemple est ce qu'on parle d'animaux
tant qu'espèce ou en tant qu'individu
mais quand on part dans un débat super
l'on s'y déroulera au de son cru les
faits pour ça c'est un truc à l'excès
avait soulevé aussi le fait que l' on
parle en tant qu'espèce et en ai parlé
rapidement que c'est bien simple via une
tante d'idiotie là dedans parce que
orangs outans n'aura pas la même
conscience qu'un euro en temps mais ça
c'est ce qu'on a toujours fait on a
toujours fait comme ça et dans ce cas là
il ya certains hommes qui pourraient
perdre leur statut d'homme tueur et ça
c'est pas aujourd'hui ce pas
envisageable en tout cas dans le bois
donc donc avance on avance on il y avait
un autre critère qui trouvait cool
alexis loisirs ici
mais parfait état pas de charge à la
fois que je cours en fait parce que je
les pages basque auquel 13 3% j'ai douze
minutes de batterie ok c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon donc par avance je trouve
que c'est pas la joie d'avoir le message
10% de la trinité faible ok parfait la
proximit la proximité avec avec l'homme
et aux côtés en fait je propose mon film
j'ai de l'animal parce que on voit que
l'est laurent autant arriver à se
projeter parce qu'il ya des fins les
symboles ce nos cousins donc c'est
relativement facile de s'identifier à ce
que je connais les commentaires youtube
elle a dit genre les singes son cousin
c'était une façon de parler on va pas
rentrer dans la voie d'évolution des
espèces ou ça de pris mais ni mallet la
plus proche de la nôtre vers laquelle on
sent qu'on s'identifie le plus bas on
s'identifie le mieux ils ont des mains
ils ont donc nous ressemble plus que des
chiens des dauphins en fait donc voilà
c'est dans la salle entreprises
nautiques mans c'est ça allait voir
l'entrepôt morphisme c'est bon je parle
chante pour une débile la ccl un panache
cette étape 2 degrés
il ya un pseudo que je trouve magique
l'orang outan la conscience d'un joueur
aussi nous différencier non oui
complètement complètement et ça s'est
passé proche de la conscience de soi en
fait c'est c'est comment dire ok je
reviens parce que oui monsieur
donc oui alex et appareils de la
proximité
la proximité avec l'homme ouais donc le
terme ne sais pas s'il est bien bien
choisie mais c'est proximité à la rose
semblance ressemblance physique
ouais je sais même pas si c'est une
question de logique ou mentaux selon moi
parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont vraiment
des gueules tortue voit donc j'ai même
pas si c'est une question de
ressemblance physique
voilà on devrait accorder des
protections d'un tu way ou alors accordé
et alexis que tu m'avais parlé d'un truc
qui était cool fouet c'était le critère
dafu bah non c'est un peu flou me chose
dira juste affinités mais en fait c'est
service ne remplit aucune des catégories
comédie avant dont l'optique qui est un
pro c'est autre chose comme tintin
l'affinité avec l'homme se serait de
dire quelle importance il a pour un seul
est donc l'exemple on avait pris c'était
parce que si par exemple quelqu'un vous
tuez un cafard cafard on est d'accord
que ça apporte pas grand chose que ça a
pas tellement conscience de soi pas
tellement conscience des autres or quand
un indice apporte pas grand chose parce
que voilà voilà
c'est non et c'est ça n'apporte pas
grand chose à la société humaine dans
l'écosystème je suis sûr que ça a son
importance mais par rapport à ce qu'on a
dit a donc voilà c'est ça moi je vais
faire je te faire le plein de trucs
qu'on a dit ça il n'a pas conscience de
toi on sait pas si la confiance de lui
on sait pas si la confiance des autres
comparé à un rat de laboratoire pour
l'instant il a pas tellement d'intérêt
ça ressemble pas tellement le du coup si
jamais dans un procès on arrivait avec
un cafard et pas ça pourrait être un
argument de poids en tant qu'humain de
dire de taper sur la table désert ce
6ème cafard personnel je vis avec lui
depuis 50 ans il a eu m'a aidé à
traverser le cancer de ma femme je ne
veux pas que vous lui fassiez du mal
voilà et la personne qui lui fait du mal
et ben ouais elle peut plus rien dire
quoi donc ce serait un c'est pas mal et
ce que j'aime bien aussi c'est que ça
aurait rebondi sur le fait qu'on a dit
que l'homme c'est nous seuls qu'on va un
peu m au dessus au dessus des autres
mais tout ça n'est pas que ce principe
moi je le dis même plus voilà il ya 1
commentaire de romain qui est encore
désolé j'insiste mais je n'arrive pas à
avancer sans avoir de réponse
smiley c'est pas trop ça me fait chier
si l'homme est le seul animal à être
capable 2 pourquoi ne serait-il pas
supérieur en fait dire ce que je pense
là dessus c'est que le seul animal qui
est capable de tout ça le truc
certes y'a plein d'animaux qui sont
capables de plein de trucs qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire et c'est à cette
image je sais pas si tu vois ta genre un
chimpanzé un poisson rouge un nul et une
girafe et genre t'as un arbre est
d'admettre qu'il dit le meilleur c'est
celui qui arrive à quimper la route tu
vois ce que je veux dire que nous on a
nos capacités il ya plein de trucs on
pourrait pas faire avec les animaux font
et puis surtout en fait c'est qu'on me
laisse seul pour l'instant à plein nez
la seule espèce à se préoccuper d'eux
donc on est obligé de prendre les
critères par rapport à nous puisque
c'est nous qui nous posons ce problème
il me semble pas que la crevette des
abysses elle se pose la question parce
que alors la crevette des abysses non
mais j'ai vu certaines crevettes déjà se
poser la question et ben écoutez avec
elle durant ce débat et puis nous
éclairer les problèmes alors il ya un
autre critère qui pourrait être
intéressant c'est l'équilibré dans
l'écosystème c'est à dire il ya des
animaux qui sont
nuisibles qui devient nuisible à leur
écosystème et il ya des animaux au
contraire qui naquit son envoi en voie
d'extinction et c est le mans cup
bah c'est justement ça se traduit en
droit puisque les lois sur la chasse
comme quoi par exemple s'il ya trop de
loups par rapport aux migé bas les
chasseurs ont tué plus de loups que
d'habitude
du coup voilà ça rejoint pau ton ton
argument mais déjà aujourd'hui toi et
tous personnellement je trouve ça assez
amusant mais que ce critère arrive à la
fin parce que au final ça pour être
considéré comme le facteur le plus
important parce que c'est celui qui
s'éloigne le plus du droit en termes
administratifs
c'est pas enfin la biodiversité c'est
vraiment quelque chose de nécessaire
pour le coup ou s'il y en a plus tout
mon coeur une vache lâche tu peux trop
d'accord puisque tu dis que c'est pas
administratif mais justement le fait de
poser des limites de chasse par exemple
c'est justement de la gestion donc c'est
administratif le fait de dire tu chasses
et parce que je suis devant ces
problèmes naturels
c'est pas un problème de conscience
c'est donc ont martelé que c'est pas un
problème de confiance et ya pas assez de
loups là-bas c'est comme dans les sims
c'est plus un véritable de problème il
n'y a pas assez de loulé bijt hond
contraire de bouffer tout le reste du
terrain c'est vraiment plus un problème
naturel que de décision de faire passer
rita le côté naturel où ça devrait se
régler tout seul mais justement nous on
se permet de régler ça en imposant des
limites
oui c'est ça mais du coup enfin le juste
je disais que c'était assez amusant de
voir que mon aurait dû en parler en
premier de sa est en fait c'est dans ma
part l'an dernier et c'est une des
choses qui est venu en interne et dans
la conversation
alors que logiquement quand on parle de
nature de protection et de choses qui
sont bénéfiques et dont on a besoin
or est normal que la biodiversité
viennent en premier dans les bagnes a
pas de fin est ce que je dis je veux pas
me positionner mais du coup c'est pas
questionnable puisque aulas avait 40
minutes on parle et on ne parle que
maintenant
oh [ __ ] c'est vrai quarante minutes on
a doublé le temps imparti
on va recentrer il ya peut-être quelques
commentaires qu'on pourrait voir
et de toute façon voilà pour juste pour
résumer du coût en termes de critères de
classification et ce qui pourrait être
intéressant c'est que vous donniez genre
d'autres critères de comment vous voyez
le truc
oui pour tous de poser des questions sur
fin vous les flotteurs avoir une
conscience de soi avoir une conscience
des autres
michou tu parlais de l'intérêt de
l'animal est ce que tu peux leur résumé
en une phrase histoire grâce à m trois
mois le fait de différenciées suivant si
l'animal il mérite qu'on lui accorde des
protections pas archi subjectif du coup
on a vu que yann son mérite
ça serait plutôt l'intérêt de l'homme
sur l'animal sur ok et nous comparer de
ça on parlait de profits sme donc en
gros au niveau de l'évolution la
proximité avec l'homme de l'affronter
avec l'animal pour un être humain en
particulier et de l' équilibre dans la
biodiversité
voilà ce qui nous fait six critères
où est donc dans les commentaires
répondre à cette question qui était
jusqu'où doit aller le droit des animaux
avaient donc on a reformulé avec
jusqu'où doit aller le devoir des hommes
en restant voilà c'est sa pratique c'est
à dire qu'on n'est pas prêt à les
abandonner par exemple bouffer
j'utilisais que c'est un débat très
intéressant à faire poursuivre du coup
pour être au fait des projets un débat
je vous invite à rejoindre la page et à
m'envoyer un mail pour participer à l'
excite a fait comment pour participer
j'ai envoyé
pas de citer mal là maintenant ouais
j'ai envoyé un mail le et toi michou il
va en fait j'ai fait pareil
voilà voilà donc ça pourrait être moi
cela n'arrive pas qu'aux autres
donc voilà c'est tout pour youtube je
pense que et ensuite tu attends vous
envoie dû laver de la pisse ya là au
revoir